il s'entraîne 12 heures par jour six
jours par semaine sur des chars qui
espèrent-ils changeront le cours de la
guerre une formation intensive volée au
par deux pour plusieurs centaines
d'Ukrainiens et cela commence sur un
simulateur car d'après les formateurs
allemands seul 20% des militaires
ukrainiens ont déjà de l'expérience dans
le maniement des blindés comme ça on ne
casse pas les machines puis vous le
voyez il y a plus de place on le fait
avec eux une fois puis il le refont et
on vérifie ensemble et il recommence
comme à l'école pour des raisons de
sécurité les Ukrainiens entraînés sur
les bases militaires en Allemagne
préfèrent cacher leur visage leur
formation de base est prévue pour durer
5 semaines contre trois mois minimum en
temps normal
nos familles pris pour qu'on soit de
retour avec ces tank le plus vite
possible
on est tous très motivés
pour les Ukrainiens limité jusqu'à
présent au char soviétiques le léopard
II est une révolution
ce formateur de l'armée allemande nous
explique pourquoi il peut faire la
différence sur le champ de bataille
le conducteur peut déplacer le véhicule
en vision nocturne aussi bien vers
l'avant que vers l'arrière
ici vous voyez bien la protection
antimine mais le gros avantage c'est ce
canon de 120 mm extrêmement stable nous
allons le constater en montant à bord
grâce à une foule de capteurs et de
systèmes informatiques le canon reste
toujours stable il peut tirer et
atteindre sa cible même en roulant à 70
km heure même sur un terrain accidenté
il faut 4 personnes pour opérer ce char
un conducteur un chargeur qui place ici
les munitions un canonnier qui effectue
le tir et un commandant
j'ai ici un appareil et en tant que
commandant je peux programmer le
chargement des munitions et c'est pas
difficile de maîtriser toute cette
technologie
non pas du tout c'est assez simple au
contraire c'est conçu pour être pratique
pour les soldats
le gouvernement à Berlin a longtemps
hésité avant de donner son feu vert à la
livraison de ses chars jugeant notamment
que leur utilisation était trop complexe
mais aujourd'hui au contraire le
racheminement vers l'Ukraine est
considéré comme une urgence
l'Allemagne promet de livrer 18
charléopards d'ici la fin du mois et
demande désormais à d'autres pays comme
le Portugal la Pologne ou la Suède
d'accélérer leur livraison